[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous sur
haut de vous retrouver pour une nouvelle
semaine de sens public 90 minutes de
débat et de reportage pour donner du
sens à l'actualité de rendez-vous 18h
22h tous les jours du lundi au jeudi sur
public Senna et voici le sommaire de ce
19 septembre c'est un débat 100%
politique que je vous propose pour
commencer avec nos experts on va
décortiquer l'actualité du week-end et
notamment la France insoumise en Pétrée
dans l'affaire Adrien catenas le député
du Nord a renoncé à ses fonctions de
coordinateur du parti et il a reconnu
avoir gifler son épouse dans cette
première partie on parlera aussi de la
réforme des retraites des journées
parlementaires du parti socialiste et de
la stratégie du rassemblement national
pour développer son ancrage territorial
comment la France peut-elle réduire de
55% ses émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2030 et atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2050 plusieurs
scénarios sont sur la table on va les
détailler dans la seconde partie de ce
sens public le défi et le taille rendre
socialement acceptable la transition
énergétique alors que le souvenir du
mouvement des gilets jaunes est toujours
brûlant
mais d'abord pour commencer la réforme
des retraites et les questions autour de
la méthode qui divise la majorité
présidentielle mathiasaraye aller vite
voilà la consigne au passé par le
Président de la République sur la
réforme des retraites alors référendum
texte de loi dédié ou simple article
dans le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale ces derniers jours
c'est cette option qui revient avec
insistance ça fait partie des procédures
qui sont possibles mais est-ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est le principal scénario
qui est retenu je vous ai dit que tout
était ouvert et vous essayez de me faire
dire à nouveau
du côté des partenaires sociaux cette
éventualité a provoqué une levée de
boucliers à commencer par la CFDT seul
grand syndicat à la table du Conseil
national de la refondation j'ai commencé
mon intervention afin ce président de la
République dans le CNR en disant on
s'inscrit dans la démarche on fait on
prend crédit de la loyauté il faudra
loyauté à tous les étages s'il y a des
Loyauté en passant par le PLFSS CFDT
arrêtera les discussions dans le cadre
du sel une manière de faire qui n'est
pas non plus du goût de François Bayrou
le poids lourd de la majorité il voit un
passage en force défavorable si on se
lance dans cette voie-là alors nous
sommes certains de coaliser d'abord les
oppositions entre elles puis de diviser
la société française un casse-tête en
prévision pour Olivier du soft qui
recevait ce lundi les partenaires
sociaux au programme évoqué le dernier
rapport du Conseil d'orientation des
retraites avec à l'esprit toujours le
calendrier dicté par l'Elysée une entrée
en vigueur à l'été 2023
les retraites les journées
parlementaires du PS et du rassemblement
national mais aussi les conséquences
politiques de l'affaire Adria catenas
beaucoup de thèmes vous l'avez vu
aborder avec mes invités Catherine
tricot bonsoir bienvenue directrice de
la revue regard anne-charline besina
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
constitutionnaliste maître de conférence
en droit public Frédéric Davy bonsoir et
bienvenue directeur général du
département Opinion de l'Ifop et
j'accueille également Mathieu croissanto
euh il te réalise politique bonsoir
Mathieu et bienvenue le ministre du
Travail on a vu l'une de ses réactions
dans dans le sujet de Mathias à
l'instant Olivier sud du socle il
recevait les syndicats aujourd'hui la
piste d'une réforme des retraites via le
budget de la Sécurité sociale et sans
doute le 49-3 n'a pas été écarté voilà
ce que les interlocuteurs du ministre
ont dit en sortant Catherine tricot
est-ce que vous croyez encore à ce qu'on
appelle pour simplifier le passage en
force
ce à quoi je crois mais en tout cas il
nous annonce il nous prépare à ce
passage en force je crois que c'est
extrêmement dangereux pour le
gouvernement c'est-à-dire que là il y a
quand même une rentrée problématique sur
plein de sujets où il est quand même
accusé de ne pas avoir pris la mesure du
réchauffement climatique du coût de
l'énergie des problèmes de pouvoir
d'achat et là il m'est remet sur le
couvercle une réforme qui a été très
contestée et pas débattue pendant
l'élection présidentielle ils avaient dû
arrêter en cours de
en 2020 avec l'arrivée du covid et puis
après de l'ensemble des manifestations
et pendant la campagne présidentielle et
notamment entre les deux tours on avait
vu la valse hésitation de d'Emmanuel
Macron donc il est pas extrêmement
légitime et là il veut y aller en force
moi je pense que là il va agacer
beaucoup de monde à commencer par la
CFDT mais pas seulement je suis pas sûr
qu'il aille au bout de la démarche
regardez c'est ses propos de la
présidente de l'Assemblée Yaël Brown
Pivet cité dans Le Parisien donc
toujours à propos de cette hypothèse un
abonnement d'un amendement via le pour
le financement de la sécurité sociale si
on fait ça tout le monde va hurler ça va
faire péter le Conseil national de la
refondation bézina c'est pas ouh là là
le CNR c'est je vois la tête de Mathieu
non mais au-delà de ça c'est vrai que on
a vu qu'il y avait pas mal de de
réactions hostiles notamment celle de
François Bayrou qui a le sens de du
timing politique unchaine blazina mais
il y a même une question de cohérence
quand même moi je trouve dans dans la
logique présidentielle il nous annonce
le soir de sa rédaction à un nouveau
une nouvelle méthode un nouveau Macron
et puis là c'est le retour de Jupiter
d'une certaine façon quoi c'est ça et
puis c'est à dire qu'en plus pour qu'on
soit capable de le produire avant la fin
du mois de décembre ça veut dire quand
même qu'on en a déjà un peu discuté en
off donc sûrement au sein des ministères
y a-t-il déjà des projets ficelés ou en
tout cas des choses préparées et ça
c'est un véritable coût pour les
Français qui avait cru que ce projet loi
serait amendé arctique par article
partenaire social par partenaire social
donc on avait vraiment le sentiment que
rien n'était fait je crois que c'est
même les mots exact du président
lorsqu'il prétendaient justement
défendre ce projet de de réforme des
retraites dans l'entre-deux-tours en
disant mais je suis homme la première
fois vous allez faire référence avec
Jean-Paul Delevoye il y avait une très
longue concertation enfin bon pour
finalement ne pas faire aboutir à la fin
pour les raisons qu'on sait donc
peut-être qu'il se dit trop trop autre
chose avec une petite nuance
c'est-à-dire que ce rapport de le voir
avait été commandé bien en amont et
c'était sur la base de ce rapport que le
projet de loi et que le projet de loi
devait passer comme tout projet de loi
devant l'Assemblée nationale tel qu'on
nous l'avait annoncé alors que là on
nous a dit Conseil national de la
refondation nous a dit dialogues
sociales donc je crois que un amendement
dans un projet de loi de financement
dont l'objet est pas d'annoncer des
réformes d'ampleur comme ça c'est-à-dire
qu'on est censé voter les équilibres
budgétaires financiers et sociaux de
l'année mais je crois vraiment que là on
joue gros en termes de légitimité
surtout sur un projet qui est bien plus
social que financier et qui est sûr de
fédérer contre lui puisque finalement il
n'intéresse tout le monde passer des
cavaliers sociaux en force c'est pas
nouveau mais généralement c'est sur des
points bien plus marginaux le cavalier
social voilà un terme de
constitutionnalisme Frédéric Daby
pourquoi ici accroche à cette réforme
elle est un populaire aujourd'hui dans
chez les Français oui c'est vrai qu'il y
a la question de la méthode c'est vrai
que il voulait très bien dit il y aura
sans doute une perte de cohérence entre
les appels au dialogues la concertation
et un 49-3 ou un article dans Le pff
dans le P et il y a aussi le fond c'est
une réforme d'une manière générale qui
suscite automatiquement la méfiance des
Français pourquoi parce qu'à chaque
réforme depuis même la réforme mon roi
de 1982 les élus les politiques les
pouvoirs publics annoncent une logique
de guerre c'est la dernière réforme pour
sauver le système ce n'est pas le cas
ici puisqu'on parle de rentrer
financière pour d'autres questions que
les retraites et il voit très bien que
il y a eu la réforme Bora Balladur
Fillon 2003 Fillon 2019 etc que on
revient sur cette réforme et puis là on
a rarement observé une hostilité aussi
forte des Français au relèvement de
l'âge de départ à la retraite j'ai
trouvé deux chiffres d'enquête Ifop
pendant la campagne présidentielle au
mois d'avril quelques jours avant le
premier tour 77% des Français il faut
vider des souhaitaient que elle Macron
retire la retraite à 65 ans de son
programme et en février 71% ça va
au-delà de
l'électorat Mélenchon Le Pen souhaitait
moyenne à la réforme à 60 ans alors
maintenant pourquoi Emmanuel Macron
s'accroche je pense que tout simplement
cette réforme des retraites il doit
peut-être apercevoir comme une sorte
d'arme de destruction massive à une
critique qui s'installe de plus en plus
fortement chez les Français c'est un
quinquennat peut-être pour rien une
action on revient peut-être au Chirac de
comment dire 2002 et c'est vrai que
cette réforme des retraites c'est une
manière pour lui pour une partie de la
pour une partie de la majorité pour une
partie minoritaire mais non négligeable
des Français la fameuse saint-alliance
sympathisant LR sympathisant lrem de
remettre le quinquennat sur les rails de
la réforme Mathieu il y a le côté il y a
ça effectivement je reste un réforme
moteur puis aussi gagner un peu de de
marge de manœuvre budgétaire c'est pas
totalement sûr juste un truc la réforme
qui avait été discutée par Jean-Paul
Delevoye souvenez-vous c'était une
réforme de refondation du système de
passer un système de retraite par point
qu'il a pour le coup nécessitait c'est
vrai un grand dialogue une grande
concertation avec syndicat et par
ailleurs je mets un petit bémol parce
que quand même pendant la campagne
présidentielle la seule mesure qu'on à
peu près retenue les gens du programme
de Macron c'est on va devoir travailler
plus longtemps alors ce que c'est 64 65
ans mais on peut pas dire que ça n'a pas
été débattu pendant la campagne
présidentielle puisque tous ces
opposants lui disaient vous allez
augmenter la retraite lui sont
expliquait pourquoi donc on peut pas
dire que ça a été un blackout total sur
cette question après pourquoi il l'a
fait d'abord parce qu'il y croit il
pense qu'il faut la faire à la fois pour
équilibrer les régimes de retraite même
si on a vu que l'an dernier et cette
année ils étaient excellentaires mais
les projections du corps montrent
qu'elles seront en tout cas pendant les
prochaines années
déficitaires et puis il veut se dégager
les marches de l'oeuvre pour faire autre
chose ça c'est raisons financière
ensuite parce qu'il veut envoyer un
signal politique c'est vrai afficher le
fait que il est un réformateur et non
pas un roi fainéant mais aussi envoyer
un signal politique à Bruxelles montrer
que la France est capable de tenir ses
engagements il faut soutenir regarder
notre niveau de déficit public
souvenez-vous de ce qu'il allait faire
en 2017 premièrement qui passe c'est les
ordonnances travail pourquoi et ben pour
envoyer un signal à Bruxelles pour
montrer que on est capable de réformer
le travail en France donc il y a aussi
un parallélisme des formes en tout cas
dans ce qu'on voit là et puis le fait
est sans doute aussi pour une question
d'opportunité tactique et là dessus
j'avoue que je suis partagé parce que
refaire des palabres sans cesse sur
comment réformer les retraites on en a
fait des centaines il y a pas 50 000
solutions il y a trois solutions c'est
très simple soit vous augmentez les
cotisations mais il a déjà écarté cette
possibilité parce qu'il ne veut pas
augmenter les impôts soit vous baissez
les pensions que les retraités touche
moins les retraités actuelles mais cette
possibilité écartée parce qu'aucun parti
ne la soutient donc il reste la seule et
la dernière solution il faut faire
travailler plus longtemps les salariés
combien comment est-ce qu'on parle en
durée de cotisation est-ce qu'on parle
en âge tout ça est connu largement connu
est-ce que ça vaut un passage en force
non on peut toujours en discuter mais en
tout cas redire il faudrait 6 mois de
débat là-dessus non et en revanche il
faut peut-être 6 mois de débat sur les
mesures accompagnatrices qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pour les carrières longues
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour la pénibilité
ça oui ça ça nécessite en tout cas c'est
un risque social évident mais je
comprends assez bien pourquoi il prend
ce que vous dites il faut il y a trois
solutions pour réformer les retraites
sauf concurrence c'est pas une réforme
des retraites qu'il vise enfin ça va
concerner les retraites mais c'est pour
des oui mais c'est pour dégager de
l'argent pour faire autre chose or
aujourd'hui quand je dis il y a quand
même un situation qui est un peu
compliquée c'est qu'il y a toute cette
polémique sur les super profits auquel
il ne s'attaque pas c'est à dire que on
lui fait reproche de laisser de côté
ceux qui vont gagner et là on attend 30
milliards sur les retraites de de gains
ça veut dire qu'en fait c'est les
salariés qui vont payer 30 milliards
alors que c'est 30 milliards c'est
inférieur au bénéfice de total c'est à
dire qu'en fait il y a quand même bien
là dans ce choix quelque chose qui ne se
justifie pas par la défense du système
de retraite par répartition mais qui se
justifie pour faire de l'investissement
soi-disant pour l'école et l'hôpital
mais en laissant de côté les super
profits donc là ça commence à faire ça
fait sens et ça fait problème d'accepter
non mais ça fait un problème
d'acceptation politique extrêmement
profonde la société
on a beaucoup de thèmes dans ce débat
donc je vous demander d'aller vite
vraiment juste un mot c'est le fait de
ne pas avoir même l'honneur d'un projet
de loi c'est un vulgaire amendement dans
un projet de voie de financement de la
sécurité sociale déjà ficelé depuis le
mois de juillet c'est vraiment ça qui
est quand même un peu choquant je trouve
et l'autre point c'est la raison c'est
pour faire des économies attention à ça
parce qu'on peut pas promettre des
chèques énergies des chèques en tout
point en ce moment on est vraiment dans
un état qui a renoué avec l'État
providence des années 30 et dire qu'on
va faire des économies sur d'autres
points il va falloir revenir au tournant
de l'argent magique doit s'arrêter ça
peut aller de pair avec la barre
budgétaire
seront à mesurer sur 10 20 30 ans donc
les économies d'échelle c'est pas
maintenant et c'est pas comme ça sur
cette question de l'acceptation des
Français ont parfaitement en tête les
trois leviers que vous avez parlé
Mathieu c'est à dire on ne baisse pas
les pensions on augmente pas les
cotisations ne reste que la durée en
fait d'allongement de départ à la
retraite et c'est vrai que en 2010
l'opinion avait basculé à une très
courte majorité sur faisons un dernier
effort pour sauver le système cette
mécanique d'opinion n'existe absolument
pas aujourd'hui sauf chez les retraités
la seule catégorie ce qui est un
massivement la réforme parce que par
définition elle ne va pas être conservée
allez j'ouvre un deuxième chapitre dans
ce débat 100% politique l'affaire
cadenas le Canard Enchaîné avait
mercredi qu'une main courante pour
violence avait été déposée par son
épouse Céline katnas 5 jours plus tard
le député du Nord a reconnu avoir giflé
sa il s'est mis en retrait de ses
fonctions au sein de les filles alors je
vous propose un premier élément pour
alimenter le le débat c'est la réaction
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon en deux temps sur
Twitter il commence ainsi je vais le
citer la malveillance policière le
voyeurisme médiatique les réseaux
sociaux se sont invités dans le divorce
conflictuel d'Adrien et Céline cattenas
Adrien décide de tout prendre sur lui je
salue sa dignité et son courage je lui
dis ma confiance et mon affection pas un
mot de soutien pour Céline katnas dans
ce premier tweet c'est forcément intolé
et ça provoque une nouvelle réaction du
leader de la France insoumise quelques
heures plus tard second tweet c'est
l'inéadrien sont tout de mes amis mon
affection pour lui ne veut pas dire que
je suis indifférent à Céline elle ne
souhaitait pas être citer mais je le dis
une GIF est inacceptable dans tous les
cas Adrien l'assume c'est bien Mathieu
que dire sur la façon dont la France
insoumise gère ou à gérer cette affaire
c'est bien simple rien ne va rien ne va
dans cette affaire et on se demande
comment la France insoumise qui compte
dans ses rangs des adversaires
on comprend qu'en gros c'est une
altercation physique et que c'est
quasiment la faute à pas de chance bah
non c'est la faute d'Adrien catanin si
on prend pas le téléphone portable de
quelqu'un contre sa volonté même si
c'est sa femme et il écrit dans ce
contexte d'annonce de séparation encore
une fois contextualisation de la
violence conjugale le député il
reconnaît avoir envoyé de trop nombreux
messages ça s'appelle du harcèlement
téléphonique en français courant et puis
enfin il évoque une gifle qui ne lui
ressemble pas c'est écrit noir sur blanc
dans le texte donner il y a un an à son
épouse dans un contexte une nouvelle
fois d'extrême tension encore un
écrit-il le tout pour finir par une
phrase d'une hypocrisie à mes yeux sans
nom je sais qu'aucune explication
qu'aucun contexte si complexe que fut la
situation ne justifie ses comportant
c'est exactement ce qu'il vient de faire
donner des raisons contextuelles à ce
qui aurait pu être un accès de violence
voilà donc le communiqué pour lequel
Adrien catin c'est lui décerner de
nombreuses félicitations ses camarades
effectivement où les paris de ces
réactions de de beaucoup de membres de
la pression parce que vous en avez parlé
on a assisté à cette occasion un
festival de compliments alors Jean-Luc
Mélenchon on l'a dit qu'il salue sa
dignité et son courage et la sœur de son
la patron des députés insoumis qui
évoluent qui évoque elle une décision
juste sage courageux Sophia chikiru il
voit la marque politique de son
honnêteté de son abnégation Daniel obono
ira même jusqu'à lui donner une forme
d'absolution en déclarant qu'il n'est ni
un [__] ni un héros mais que les
violences conjugales sont une réalité
systémique sous-entendent c'est la faute
du système foi et continuer la liste
mais là on se dit qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans la tête de ces gens-là qui nous
font passer Adrien Catalin ce qui vient
de reconnaître avoir été violent avoir
eu un comportement violent et des gestes
violents avec sa femme pour un père
courage sans aucune marque vous l'avez
souligné tout à l'heure d'attention ou
de compassion pour sa victime c'est bien
simple elle n'existe plus en langage
féministe on dirait qu'elle s'est fait
silencier et qu'elle s'est fait
invisibiliser ça c'est la seconde faute
et puis pour parachever le tout il y a
la troisième faute Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui se charge de dénoncer la
malveillance policière le voyeurisme
médiatique car il serait là selon lui
les vraies responsables mais du coup si
Adrien Catalins n'est plus le vrai
responsable le plus coupable c'est qu'il
y a plus de victimes et là réside je
disais la troisième erreur et à mon avis
c'est sans doute
parlementaires le temps voilà de la vie
privée et ici on a encore plus de ça se
télescope complètement étant donné que
en termes judiciaire il faut bien dire
une main courante c'est censé être
quelque chose de totalement confidentiel
la personne que vous accusez n'a pas
droit au dossier il n'y a pas de
contradictoire donc on a ici à faire une
lettre qui va jouer le rôle de droit de
la défense finalement qui elle-même est
publiée sur un réseau qui est celui de
Twitter qui est plutôt le tribunal
médiatique par excellence donc on voit
bien qu'on a complètement marginalisé le
temps judiciaire alors c'est quelque
chose qui nous dit
quel est l'aire du temps et l'air du
temps il est à cette idée que il y a de
la réputation de l'honneur de l'image
que nous donne les politiques et je
pense au débat que nous avons eu il y a
pas si longtemps sur le fou rire de
Kylian Mbappé quand on lui parle du char
à voile qui qui nous dit que il y a des
choses qui deviennent intolérables et
évidemment on tente de parler des
violences faites aux femmes avec
comme vous le dit de la légèreté parfois
aussi beaucoup de maladresse et bien ça
devient quelque chose de politiquement
répréhensible il faut bien avoir en tête
que politiquement il est encore député
et que en termes constitutionnel il n'y
a rien à se reprocher puisqu'il n'y a
même pas encore alors si maintenant le
parquet de Lille s'est saisi de la
totale
de fait donc voilà on peut dire que on
peut dire ça je trouve que c'est
important dans un on est un lieu de
débat qui peut être assez subtil je
l'espère en tout cas on peut dire ça
sans excuser en rien les violences
conjugales enfin vous voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est il y a aucune aucune
espèce de de doute dans mon esprit mais
c'est quand même une vraie question la
parce que le point de départ
il y a effectivement une main courante
avec ce qu'on comprend une volonté que
ça ne soit pas médiatisée exactement de
la part des deux c'est ce qui a été dit
en tout cas c'est ce qui a été exprimé
le grand risque c'est à dire que on en
arrive à de voir se justifier de
demander du temps de demander du doute
sur certaines questions de demander des
enquêtes de demander une justice parce
que on est soupçonné parfois d'être du
côté de celui qui fait donc il faut
faire attention je pense à ne pas
rentrer dans une société du casier
judiciaire qui consiste à essayer
d'avoir des politiques qui soient blanc
de tout soupçon mais en ayant finalement
conscience que c'est le peuple qui
décide de ce qui est mis en mal on se
rappelle de l'ancien régime c'est
dangereux et évidemment il y a des
violences faites aux femmes qui qui sont
des combats qui sont menés depuis des
années sur lesquels notre droit pénal
est vraiment très en retard par rapport
au système espagnol on l'a déjà dit il y
a beaucoup de choses à faire au niveau
de la prévention et du débat mais voilà
faisons attention à pas sacrifier trop
moi je crois que ce qui est difficile
dans cette affaire c'est que ça vient de
la France insoumise en plus c'est-à-dire
que ça c'est quand même pas tout à fait
anodin et la France insoumise à cette
caractéristique un peu spéciale d'être
un parti qui est dans sa culture d'abord
composite il est pas homogène et il a
une partie de sa culture qui vient de
militant très
je cherche mes mots mais un peu
viriliste c'est à dire qu'il y a quand
même une culture de langagement de la on
tient debout on est même on a des mots
un peu durs on lâche rien etc il y a une
et puis d'avant-garde d'être aussi une
culture d'avant-garde tout le monde sait
oui mais à côté de ça il y a beaucoup de
militants de féministes ça ne fait pas
c'est pour ça que je dis qu'elle est
composite cette partie est composée
c'est qu'il y a d'un côté ça et de
l'autre côté des féministes et qui ont
qui font entendre leur voix et qui ont
porté à l'intérieur de la France
insoumise un discours absolument
intraitable sur les violences faites aux
femmes dans leurs différentes donc du
coup
certaines d'entre elles non mais moi
dans les réactions
à partir du moment où il a reconnu les
fesses ça devient effectivement
je ne parle pas de ces femmes là en
particulier je parle de la culture du
fait que par exemple la réaction de
Caroline Dehar de
le samedi il faut après le premier tweet
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
elle-même membre de la France insoumise
mais le poids des féministes compte à
l'intérieur de la France insoumise et
donc je crois que il y a cette espèce de
tension qui était déjà très très forte
au moment de l'affaire à boire et encore
plus au moment de la faire Coquerel ça
ça c'était monté très très haut mais
est-ce que ça révèle aussi une question
de gouvernance au sein de fi mais
clairement et d'ailleurs Clémentine
Autain se plaint amèrement qu'il n'y ait
pas eu de réunion de la France insoumise
pour discuter de la réaction à tenir
c'est-à-dire que pour l'instant Jean-Luc
Mélenchon après l'affaire Coquerel avait
dit il va bien falloir qu'on se penche
sur un sujet et qu'on mette à jour notre
doctrine ça n'a pas été fait et ils sont
rattrapés par l'affaire Catena c'est à
dire que je pense que il y a bien une
question qui va devoir articuler le
droit des femmes le droit le droit pénal
la juste le droit à la justice et une
exemplarité quand on est une
organisation politique qui se veut
engager sur les droits des femmes
Frédéric Dhabi est-ce que l'opinion est
un peu
non comme moi à la fois gêné parce qu'on
voilà on s'est quand même la vie privée
d'un couple et en même temps
passionné parce que il y a des enjeux
politiques qui est des enjeux sociétaux
qui sont profonds enfin voilà on dit on
va trop vite mais on est tellement allé
lentement pendant des décennies sur la
question des violences faites aux femmes
que il est temps que ça bouge vous avez
absolument tout dit ça a été très bien
dit c'est vrai que c'est d'abord une
affaire privée le communiqué du Canard
Enchaîné suite à l'article du Canard
Enchaîné mais c'est un sujet qui je
dirais maintenant préoccupe passionne
intéressent les Français et sur lesquels
le clivage ce genre que l'on observait
en fait auparavant c'est à dire c'est un
sujet qui en fait intéresse plus ces
femmes que les hommes existent toujours
notamment chez les jeunes femmes mais
qui sait très fortement atténué c'est
une affaire qui à mon avis intéresse
parce que elle touche une personnalité
qui n'est pas n'importe qui à la France
insoumise c'est un des héritiers
possible de Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a un
lien très fort entre eux qui rappelle le
lien qu'entenait Jean-Luc Mélenchon avec
feu François de la pierre qui était son
héritier avant dans les années 2012 2014
et puis cette question cette affaire il
y a une question qui se pose est-ce que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est un atout ou un
handicap pour la nups son premier tweet
vous l'avez très bien dit enfin Mathieu
il y a une virée et une véritable fait
catastrophe ça accrédite un récit
l'affaire tabouaf la faire extrêmement
différentes et c'est par exemple sont
présumé innocentes l'affaire fait Catena
ce qui accrédite l'idée que Jean-Luc que
dans l'impression
stigmatise les médias et de crédibilité
de elle est fille et pas ricochet de la
nupette les Français font l'équation
suivante pour l'instant et les français
de gauche nups
Mélenchon la seule incarnation crédible
aujourd'hui et visible de la nupcesse
c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon et dans une
enquête ifope pour l'humanité une
majorité de personnes se positionnant à
gauche ont le sentiment plutôt pronostic
que la nupestre n'est qu'une coalition
électorale qui n'ira pas au bout qui
n'est pas une force d'alternative à par
exemple Emmanuel Macron ou une force
concurrente par rapport au rassemblement
national ce type ce type d'affaires ne
va pas dans le sens d'une crédibilité de
la nipples sur un sujet qui je le répète
intéresse autant les Français et ils ont
tel a fait un cheval de bataille parce
que comme le dicatrine il y a un réflexe
de corps de camaraderie sans doute un
peu viril dans les premiers tweets de
soutien parce que on dit ah bah Adrien
katana c'est pas on le connaît c'est un
bon mec oui enfin les gens qui tapent
leur femme sont toujours au départ des
bons mecs voilà et ça ne justifie pas
les violences et puis il y a aussi un
réflexe de mettre la quête caché la
poussière sous le tapis ça c'est ce
qu'on a vu plutôt dans les affaires
précédentes du type Coquerel ou du type
euh et tout ça est orthogonal avec un
des combats assumé et dit prioritaires
de la France insoumise qu'elle a lutte
contre les violences sexy c'est sexuel
donc c'est une affaire privée oui mais
sur un sujet éminemment politique et
quand vous êtes en contradiction et ben
ça pète et ça fait des dégâts profond il
y a qu'à lire quand vous regardez les
réactions des militants pas forcément
des élus les beaucoup de militants et
militantes sont écoeurés de la façon
dont ces sujets sont sont sont mises en
scène ou exposées ou en tout cas réguler
par par la France insoumise
qui est très dur quand ça se passe ce
type d'affaires se passe dans les autres
et c'est normal c'est le jeu politique
mais pour le coup très embêté très
embarrassé quand ça se passe chez elle
avec une question aussi au sein de la
nupesse écoutez la réaction de Sandrine
Rousseau député Europe Écologie Les
Verts il est indispensable qu'il quitte
la coordination du mouvement en effet je
pense qu'il faut qu'il se mette en
retrait de toute de toute parole
publique et voir en retrait du groupe
LFI à l'Assemblée nationale on est les
violences conjugales les violences
envers les femmes sont absolument
inadmissibles et il les a reconnu donc
contact parce que c'est pas si courant
que ça les personnes qui reconnaissent
les violences n'ont pas qu'il l'a fait
maintenant il doit se mettre en retrait
de vraiment de toute parole politique
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible de
représenter les hommes et les femmes et
d'avoir une parole au nom des hommes et
des femmes quand on a été on s'est rendu
coupable de telzach on va boucler ce
débat il nous reste beaucoup d'autres
thèmes un cha là c'est une forme de
bannissement ou d'auto bannissement on
peut qui peut durer puisqu'à partir du
moment parce qu'on décrivait tout à
l'heure
qu'est-ce qui pourrait inverser la
tendance pour Adrien 4 nains
ça va durer difficile de répondre à
cette question je rajouterais quand même
certains points c'est que on voit bien
dans le vocabulaire de Sandrine Rousseau
que rien n'est du ressort de la faute de
la pénalisation du droit etc elle est
dans la réputation d'en parler au nom
d'eux et je crois qu'elle a raison de
distinguer les deux et on disait le
temps judiciaire n'est pas le temps
politique et aujourd'hui je pense qu'on
peut acter du fait que une certaine
morale politique fait que on ne peut pas
tolérer d'un responsable politique
quelque chose qu'on ne tolérerait pas de
son voisin et que cette idée de
l'égalité devant la justice elle
s'incarne aussi dans le discours dans ce
qu'on peut représenter en termes de
valeur donc je pense que on touche ici à
un problème très important ce qu'on a
dit de la culture LFI plein de choses
vraies mais je pense aussi qu'on touche
ici au fait que c'était peut-être une
erreur d'en faire le fleuron d'un parti
politique et même d'avoir des organes
internes aux partis politiques pour
entendre les violences faites aux femmes
il y a quelque chose qui pour moi
vraiment une sorte des limites du droit
parce que ça n'est pas à un organe
politique de gérer ces questions même
faire comme si de rien n'était et il
faut il faut bien qu'il les
appréhende ces questions ça c'est une
question politique c'est une question
individuelle c'est une question que
fonctionne pas on règle interne toute
entreprise pardon je parle en même temps
que vous c'est très désagréable mais
comme tout entreprises une entreprise
qui est conforme à un cas de de
harcèlement ou un câble enfin elle doit
s'en elle doit s'en préoccuper la DRH
doit s'en préoccuper pourquoi un parti
politique en serait exemple vous voyez
ce que je veux dire bien sûr mais ça se
passe différemment dans une entreprise
déjà il y a des droits de la défense
c'est-à-dire que vous êtes convoqué on
vous explique pourquoi vous avez le
temps de voilà de vous mettre en retrait
parce que généralement vous le souhaitez
vous-même également pour présenter une
défense c'est associer à un temps
judiciaire alors que ici il faut réagir
voilà dans le temps médiatique il faut
réagir encore plus vite et attention à
ne pas gérer ça de manière encore plus
étouffée moi je crois que le parti
politique c'est une bonne chose et ça
peut être un dernier mot je vous rejoins
tout à fait qu'il y a une question sur
la gestion à l'intérieur des
organisations politiques ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il ne faut pas le faire bien sûr
c'était d'ailleurs on ne s'est quitté
l'été avec cette question en disant il
va bien falloir trouver voilà sur la
faire Coquerel on s'était quitté en
disant bon il a la France insoumise à un
projet à résoudre on fait une question à
résoudre moi ce que je pense c'est que
en effet le sujet là il n'est pas
d'ordre judiciaire probablement que ça
ne n'ira pas très très loin j'en sais
rien mais on peut penser au vu de ce qui
a été rendu public ça n'ira pas très
loin sur le plan judiciaire par contre
sur le plan politique les dégâts sont
très lourds et à mon avis difficile à
surmonter et à remonter après apprendre
à avoir fait son combat la petite phrase
de Sandrine Rousseau elle est quand même
assez effrayante parce que ça équivaut à
une mort politique et un bannissement
cru que un homme qui a fait une faute ou
quelqu'un comme une erreur peut quand
même la comprendre la réparer et que
l'individu est immandable c'est quand
même au cœur de la position de gauche et
là on a l'impression que c'est fini avec
ta mince et en voyant les poubelles le
soir on va parler maintenant des
journées parlementaires à la fois du
Parti socialiste et puis ensuite du
rassemblement
national et journée parlementaires du PS
qui se déroulent à Rennes où l'on
retrouve en direct Audrey Vittaz bonjour
bonsoir Audrey le PS qui se cherche une
ligne politique au sein de l'accord des
gauches
oui car même si tout le monde l'admet
l'accord nupes a permis aux parties
socialiste de sauver les meubles et de
garder un groupe à l'Assemblée nationale
malgré le très mauvais score Dany dalgo
à la présidentielle je le rappelle 1,7 %
se pose désormais la question de l'après
écoutez
là j'ai envie de vous dire avec la nuit
pêche on a quand même gagné un
certificat de conformité de gens de
gauche et donc maintenant c'est comment
dans cette gauche on trouve une place
qui aura plus d'écos que 1,7%. voilà
voilà enfin en tout cas la feuille de
route du parti c'est ça
les socialistes sont conscients qu'il
peut y avoir des combats communs comme
la taxation sur les super profits qui
fera l'objet d'une proposition de loi
déposer cette semaine et soutenue par
l'ensemble de la gauche certains offres
s'interrogent sur la capacité de la
France insoumise force majoritaire de la
nupesse à gouverner c'est ici que le
Parti socialiste pourrait avoir un coup
à jouer il rappelle qu'il détient encore
100 villes de plus de 30 000 habitants
et qu'il est le premier groupe
parlementaire si on prend l'ensemble des
deux assemblées écoutez je suis
intimement convaincu que le Parti
socialiste a une place spécifique lui
fait même qu'il a amené la gauche quatre
fois au pouvoir dans la cinquième
république donc le Parti socialiste
c'est vrai peut-être moins comment je
vais vous dire moins voyante qu'il ne
l'a été à une époque
mais nous ne sommes voilà en train de de
rebondir
le chef du groupe socialiste au Sénat
qui a appelé dès ce matin dès son
discours d'ouverture à être dans le
rapport de force même avec les
partenaires même avec les amis certains
vont même plus loin comme le sénateur de
Paris David Assouline pour qui le PS
doit se différencier au plus vite de la
France insoumise pour que la gauche
espère remporter de nouvelles élections
nous reviendra pas au pouvoir si le
centre de gravité qui est celui
d'aujourd'hui reste celui d'aujourd'hui
on le sait y compris on pourrait
très rapidement perdre nos vies et puis
dans la prochaine échéance électorale
qui qui avait une science européenne
perdre notre identité réponse
à ceux qui dans son propre camp imagine
déjà un ticket commun nups pour les
prochaines élections européennes pour
lui c'est impossible le Parti socialiste
et la France insoumise sont trop divisés
sur ce sujet merci Audrey Audrey des
journées parlementaires du PSA à Rennes
tient ce sondage
ifope Frédéric Dhabi la question on
dirait vous que la nuque donc nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale
vous semble être avant tout une
coalition électorale amenée à se désunir
et même à disparaître
73% pour cette affirmation ou alors un
rassemblement amené à 100 à signer dans
le paysage politique 27%, pourquoi les
Français sont-ils aussi sceptiques
parce que il voit à mon avis les
différences idéologiques programmatiques
d'incarnation au sein des différentes
fragments composantes de la news alors
auprès des auprès des auprès de
sympathisants de gauche c'est un sur
deux mais c'est quand même beaucoup et
c'est ce clivage qui traverse ces
journées parlementaires du PS force
locale très forte inexistante sur le
plan national dans notre baromètre il
faut Fiducial pour match on a seulement
6% ou 7 % des Français au mois de
septembre qui considèrent que le PS
incarne bien l'opposition à Emmanuel
Macron 10% pour des écolos et presque
30% pour la France insoumise quand je
disais on va dire l'équation 40 on va y
venir pour le rassemblement ou bien au
coude à coup avec la France insoumise
mais c'est vrai que l'équation nups
égale en fait elle est fi elle est
complètement partagée par les Français
donc quelle solution pour le PS est-ce
qu'on reste sur ce court thermisme ou
grâce à l'UPS c'est vrai et suite au
score Academy de Dan Hidalgo a permis de
sauver beaucoup de débuter mais en
termes de projection vers l'avenir elle
est beaucoup plus malaisée que devient
le PS si il reste dans si ce rapport de
force pour les Français et auprès des
sympathisants de gauche sur qui incarne
le mieux la gauche aussi lui aussi
défavorable et il
a une il a un vrai risque de finir comme
à partir absolument marginalisé et
existant qu'à travers des confettis
locaux même s'ils sont même si c'est
compétit sont importants oui oui il
reste quand même important un challenge
business qu'on est en train d'assister à
une sorte de mutation de nos partis
politiques ah oui moi je crois je crois
qu'en fait on est revenu un petit peu
aux origines de la Cinquième République
ou à cause de l'histoire de la quatrième
on avait beaucoup de parties de
coalition comme ça où on avait des des
familles au sein desquelles on sentait
bien que des des oppositions
bouillonnais et j'ai le sentiment en
effet qu'on s'oriente un peu là dessus
mais c'est pas une tendance uniquement
française ça se voit en Espagne en
Italie en Allemagne en Autriche mais
dans les pays nordiques maintenant on ne
peut plus vraiment réunir de majorité
qu'une fois coalisée il y a très peu
d'opinions complètement stables sur des
parties de gouvernement
traditionnels droits de gauche donc on
assiste en effet à une recomposition des
forces autour de de voilà de
micronébuleux qui sont à la fois un peu
partisanes et un peu social qui se
coalise entre elles mais ça veut pas
dire pour autant à mon avis que la
droite et la gauche dans leur opposition
binaire noir et blanc un peu un peu
manichéenne soit complètement morte et
je pense que le PS joue gros en ce
moment sur son identité pas uniquement
sur les prochaines européennes mais il
faudrait qu'on arrive à savoir si
justement la gauche est celle des allocs
ou celle du travail toutes ces questions
là elles sont loin d'être anecdotiques
la gauche a perdu un peu tous les
éléments qui faisaient son discours le
progrès les classes sociales le service
public et donc il y a des fondamentaux
sur lesquels je pense que l'opinion
attend des réponses sur lesquelles la
gauche doit se repositionner rapidement
avant de se laisser un peu
dans le courant wokis la la mouvance un
peu LFI dont on a dit d'ailleurs toute
la tout le caractère composé je crois
pas que ce soit d'ailleurs très unanime
non plus dans ce partie là donc il y a
des choses à régler en terme d'identité
allez il nous reste un peu moins de 7
minutes et je voudrais qu'on y consacre
notre dernière actualité donc le
rassemblement national Steve Jourdain
vous pouvez nous rejoindre bonsoir Steve
qui organisait le RN ses journées
parlementaires également c'était ce
week-end c'était au Cap d'Agde et
c'était l'occasion pour Marine Le Pen de
fixer un horizon fixer le cap au Cap
d'Agde on peut dire ça comme objectif
2023 Thomas pour le rassemblement
national vous savez ce qui va se passer
en 2023 les élections sénatoriales
évidemment elles auront lieu au mois de
septembre le RN ne compte aujourd'hui
aucun élu à la Chambre haute mais Marine
Le Pen bien elle veut que ça change
j'écoutais là
les prochaines élections sénatoriales
qui auront lieu en 2023 corrigeront je
l'espère c'est inconvenance démocratique
qui perdure au Sénat ce déni
démocratique prive la Haute Assemblée
d'une part de sa nécessaire
représentativité et je le sais d'une
énergie nouvelle qui lui serait
grandement profitable et le maître mot
de cette rentrée à ce moment national
c'est alternance oui c'est le deuxième
étage de la fusée Le Pen après avoir
envoyé 89 députés à l'Assemblée
nationale le RN veut devenir un parti
comme les autres il se présente
désormais comme le seul parti de
l'alternance l'alternance pour la France
c'est le slogan qui a été choisi par
Marine Le Pen pour son discours ce
week-end ça c'est pour l'objectif et
pour y parvenir l'URL veut miser sur son
ancrage territorial écouter là je lance
d'ores et déjà un appel aux élus de
France au maire et aux grands électeurs
attachés au pluralisme à se mobiliser
avec nous pour la défense de cette
démocratie de proximité que sont les
communes même les plus petites le temps
presse mère et élu ruraux avez-vous
entendu Emmanuel Macron il y a quelques
jours
il ne propose rien de moins que de vous
imposer l'installation dans vos villages
et vos villes d'une immigration que vous
n'avez pas demandée
d'ailleurs dans les faits Steve est-ce
que le rassemblement national est
effectivement le parti de la ruralité on
va commencer par dire ce qu'est la
ruralité un selon l'Insee la ruralité
représente 88% des communes françaises
c'est 33% de la population totale au
second tour de la présidentielle Marine
Le Pen a remporté plus de 18000 communes
sur les 35 000 que compte la France elle
est même imbattable un pratiquement dans
les villages puisqu'elle arrive en tête
dans 57% des communes de moins de 1000
habitants la tendance est confirmée aux
élections législatives au deuxième tour
le RN là emporté dans plus de 9600
communes sur 35000 la plupart de ces
communes se trouvent effectivement dans
les zones rurales bref en résumé
aujourd'hui les zones rurales préfèrent
le RN et c'est bien sûr ces zones que le
parti veut capitaliser pour continuer à
se normaliser pourquoi pas obtenir un
jour un groupe au Sénat merci beaucoup
Steve Jourdain pour toutes ces
explications Catherine tricot
l'alternance la seule ou la véritable
alternance voilà le slogan de Marine Le
Pen pour cette rentrée et sans doute
pour plusieurs mois voire plusieurs
années
aujourd'hui c'est pas totalement faux
est-ce crédibilise et elle continue
c'est à dire que là en même on s'en
crant dans il y a le contexte
international qui va quand même la
porter qui commence déjà à l'apporter la
semaine prochaine
et aux élections qui viennent en Italie
exactement vous en avez parlé la semaine
dernière et c'est tout à fait une
question qui va secouer Europe 1 c'était
arrivé au pouvoir probable de l'extrême
droite en Italie donc elle est portée
sur le plan international elle est
portée par la position qu'elle a acquise
à l'intérieur de l'hémicycle et sa
position je dirais de elle n'exagère pas
c'est à dire que par rapport à la France
insoumise qui amplifie les colères les
réactions et qui jouent le bruit dans le
dans l'hémicycle elle elle veut faire la
dame raisonnable et je pense que ça ça
fonctionne avec un pays profond qui est
notamment celui des campagnes mais celui
des campagnes il est à la fois d'abord
il faut pas négliger c'est que la France
reste historiquement un pays de campagne
donc on a dans nos familles des gens
dans les campagnes nos familles
on en vient effectivement on en revient
tous Voilà absolument donc c'est pas du
tout une histoire oubliée et la deuxième
chose c'est que ça ça installe sa
crédibilité c'est à dire que L2 elle
s'est nationalisée par le campagne elle
devient un
pas simplement un parti localisé dans le
Nord-Pas-de-Calais mais elle se
nationalise et elle donne d'avoir une
solution une crédibilité politique
ça fait combien de temps que le RN est
sorti de ses fiefs ou dites le Nord le
sud-est il y a eu quand même la
présidentielle de 2017 même si le
rapport de force a été extrêmement
défavorable à Marine Le Pen elle vient
maintenant et maintenant attrape tout
c'est vrai que la question des campagnes
dans nos enquêtes aujourd'hui vote elle
était quasiment en tête au premier tour
ça a été bien dit à 50% 55 au second
tour elle a joué sur le déclin du pays
qui est qui est un moteur très puissant
qui a je dirais fait mobilisé une partie
de
l'électorat du monde et elle a aussi ça
a pas été dit mais c'est le deuxième
pilier le salariat n'oublions pas qu'au
premier tour elle est arrivée en tête
chez les salariés français c'est elle
qui est la première avait parlé en
septembre 2021 donc bien avant la crise
de l'énergie et bien sûr l'invasion
russe de la question de l'énergie du
pouvoir d'achat et c'est vrai que
maintenant elle quitte quand même ses
habits de Cassandre pour annoncer des
catastrophes c'est ce que faisait Éric
Zemmour pour maintenant être sur la
proposition et c'est vrai que c'est vrai
aussi qu'elle joue de plus en plus
fortement sur la distinction par rapport
à une France insoumise éruptive celle du
bruit et de la fureur et qui est sur une
logique très minutieienne pour elle
constituée non pas l'alternance mais
l'alternative au macronisme et c'est
plus facile sur ce quinquennat là que le
principal intéressé ne pourra pas se
présenter mais mais si on fait référence
si on va conclure là dessus anne-charles
busina ce qui se passe en Suède et ce
qui va peut-être se passer en Italie
il y a une question d'alliance des
droites quand même qui se pose là-bas et
qui va se poser en France est-ce que le
rassemblement national peut accéder au
pouvoir
national dans une élection nationale
sans une alliance avec le parti LR la
question se posera les cinq prochaines
années à venir
je remarque néanmoins que que le
rassemblement national joue des trous
dans la raquette de l'arène c'est-à-dire
que les territoires la puissance
notamment fiscale de ces territoires
elle a été beaucoup moins de riz sous le
premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron et
la reine n'a jamais réussi son ancrage
local donc ça prouve bien que il y a un
manque dans le parti majoritaire à ce
niveau là sur lequel c'est très facile
de s'en créer et j'ajoute que les
somewher et les anywhere qui étaient un
peu le les deux les deux les deux tant
qu'on essayait de de faire se battre en
2017 sont encore très présents c'est à
dire que l'ancrage local face aux
citoyens du monde c'est ceux qui se
jouent en Italie en Suède c'est la
manière dont on a de sentir sa nation je
terminerai par cette très jolie phrase
de de
Gambetta sur le Sénat qui n'est en
parler comme du Grand Conseil des
communes de France donc s'il est vrai
que le RN arrive à parler aux communes
peut-être a-t-il un avenir au Sénat
avoir ce sera l'enjeu de des élections
sénatoriales la saison prochaine merci
beaucoup merci à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce premier